يعرف هذا المسجد بالمسجد الازرق ومن بعيد
يبدو بمركز همبرجر اسلامي مجرده مسجدا
للصلاه ولكن المركز يثير مخاوف المعارضين
الايرانيين هنا الذين بداوا يتظاهرون
امامه ويثير ايضا قلق المخابرات الالمانيه
التي تراقبه منذ العام
1993 هذه السيده الايرانيه الالمانيه تروج
منذ سنوات لاغلاقه تقول تركيا
اليوم
بالنسبه لهم الشريعه تعلو فوق الدستور هنا
ما يعني بان العاملين في المركز لا
يحترمون القانون الاساسي في المانيا ولا
الدستور ويريدون ان نشر ايديولوجيههم عبر
كامل اوروبا وهي افكار ارهابيه
ويعرف السيسي هنا في همبرجر جيدا الدوره
التي يلعبه المركز في تركيا
يتحدث عن دور نموذج للمركز الذي يعين
رئيسه مباشره من طهران ويقول انه يلعب دور
سياسيا ودينيا ولكن فيزوكي يرفض اتهامات
احزاب المعارضه بالتردد في اغلاقه
ولا يكفي ان تقرر بعض الاحزاب السياسيه
الاغلاق لانه هناك اجراءات قانونيه ليس من
الضروري ان ياتي هذا الطلب من السياسيين
لان المركز اصلا تحت المراقبه وسيبقى كذلك
وان كانت هناك مناسبه لاغلاقه فسيتم
اغلاقه
تقدم بطلب من قبل ايام لمجلس الشورى الذي
ينضوي المركز تحته من اتفاق مع حكومه
همبرج لطرد المركز الاسلامي منه خطوه قد
تكون الاولى باتجاه اغلاقه
المخابرات الالمانيه تصف هذا المركز بانه
اهم اداه بروباندا لايران في اوروبا
بجامعات ارهابيه مثل حزب الله والحوثيين
والان بعد عقود من السماح له بالعمل بحريه
قد تكون ايام المركز الاسلامي فيها برج
باتت معدوده